russia looks like it's preparing for
military action against ukraine
a hundred thousand soldiers have amassed
along the border supported by russian
armor and artillery that could move
quickly if necessary the plan for a
lightning war that could take out kiev
is one that everybody
can see
is russia planning invasion or using
smoke and mirrors to push nato into
doing what it wants this is all putin i
don't think even his people know for
certain what he's going to do but if
this isn't a bluff and putin really is
planning to invade ukraine this is what
it would look like on the front line for
ukraine and everyone else as well
russia may want to invade in winter on
solid frozen ground perfect conditions
for tanks at the moment the weather's
been too mild in ukraine for a proper
freeze
even if the ground freezes within weeks
russia may not have long to invade
before the ice thaws and its machinery
risks being bogged down
the intelligence is very clear that
there are 60 russian battle groups about
six russian battle groups on the borders
of of ukraine russia's soldiers are
being moved into prime positions though
on the 18th of january russia announced
it had moved troops to belarus for joint
military exercises giving it the option
of attacking ukraine from the north east
and south
but the preparations being reported
aren't just ground and air forces if
there's going to be an invasion the
kremlin will use a whole range of
different tactics
hackers linked to belarusian
intelligence agencies and ally of russia
attach ukrainian government websites at
the beginning of january although the
sites were quickly secured some experts
say the hackers may have been testing
access and leaving back doors into the
system
[Music]
there's also the movement of russia's
amphibious ships from the baltic sea
potentially towards ukraine's most
important port odessa russia's held navy
drills in the black sea and six assault
ships are making their way through the
mediterranean to a training exercise
with fears they could then make their
way to ukraine's shores
however many have dismissed this as a
distraction technique amphibious
exercises are expensive and russia has
never attempted one in the past
rush is also moving ships through the
english channel the straits of gibraltar
and the straits of istanbul for the
world and particularly the west to see
intelligence officials in the uk and us
also say the kremlin is preparing for
political control of ukraine according
to a declassified letter ukrainian
politician yevhen maryam is russia's
pick to lead a new government he's
staunchly pro-russian and sees the west
influence over kiev and its president as
a hostage situation
mariah has strongly denied the claims
around 100 000 russian troops are
reported to have gathered along its 1200
mile border with ukraine it's sought to
have just over a million authorized
personnel in its ranks about 280 000 of
them in ground forces that's compared to
ukraine's 150 000 combat-ready troops
although that sounds like a stark
difference the last time ukraine went to
war with russia it had only 6 000 combat
ready troops certainly in a better
position than it was then if there were
to be a large-scale invasion of ukraine
are you confident that your forces would
be able to resist and push them back
ukraine has the support of the west and
nato despite not being a nato member
uk troops have been in the country since
2015 training ukrainian soldiers and in
response to russia's latest military
aggression britain has sent thirty elite
troops and two thousand anti-tank
weapons
principe island nicolas
galaxy
nato is putting forces on standby and
sending additional ships and fighter
jets to its deployments in eastern
europe spain is sending ships to join
nato naval forces france has expressed
its readiness to send troops to romania
under nato command
and the netherlands is sending two f-35
fighter jet aircraft to bulgaria from
april to support nato's air policing
activities in the region the united
states has also said it's considering
increasing its military presence in
eastern europe vladimir putin has made
explicit threats about military action
if his demands are not met if that means
an invasion of ukraine some experts
predict violence in europe on a scale
not seen since the second world war